il est l'heure d'aller faire les courses
de dernière minute parce que là
franchement je suis comme d'habitude
très très à la bourre c'est ma grande
spécialité ça généralement les achats de
noël ça serai toujours un quart d'heure
avant sinon c'est pas drôle aujourd'hui
la vidéo sera un tout petit peu plus
courte pour cause de réveillon donc au
programme de la journée ce matin
quelques courses de dernière minute
petit déj rapide avec
mon frangin michael que vous avez vues
dans la vidéo d'ailleurs dire si vous
l'avez regardé
ensuite petit montage rapide vous
embrasse mon petit claque sur les fesses
tout fait un gros bisou pour noël et
puis ensuite va sera mon tour de
festoyer
je pratique ouvertement gay à la bourre
comme d'habitude ses potes qu'ils soient
entendus
bonjour salle émue hier ça pique un peu
grâce à mickey on est membre du culte
qui nous explique le kent en chef
rebelle en fait on est un peu bon ok
c'est quand le hellfest cette année
c'est mijoux me joins donc me joins on
part tous les deux au hellfest
ouais enfin wife est en vip grâce auquel
tu vas dire qu'on aura accès à des
choses aux personnes aura accès à cette
année en poussant têtes d'affiché
aerosmith un dernier concert d'aerosmith
au monde mais en fait le coeur
il ya plein de punch choisi un club il
ya un grand écran il ya plein de basilic
vie on peut voir là tous les concerts
sur une terrasse dans des petites
chaises longues enfin billet plein d'âme
à plein d'avantagés céderont shot et or
est pas mal mais il ya plein de filles
tatouées aussi le effet si vous ne savez
pas c'est le plus gros festival de métal
en france un festival qui est monstrueux
cette année à la fiche il yad'énormes
groupes qui viennent
deep purple aerosmith linkin park
airborne slayer trust rang ci-dessus
cheadle tel n 6 creator et plaindre des
centaines de groupes qui seront là sur
la scène de clisson ça sera monstrueux
ça c'est la boxe kuyt va me permettre de
pouvoir accéder à tout tout tout tout ce
que je veux au club du hellfest
regardez c'est marqué dessus et alors à
l'intérieur vous avez des choses qui
sont complètement incroyable a dit mme
diop a baissé un peu la cam voilà bien
par l'ama petit voilà alors regardons
qu'est-ce qu'on est dans des heurts
entre nos incroyables
génial f s
cult forme 4e
4e quelques vraiment faire de vous un
packaging ce truc à l'intérieur et dia
le porte-clés d'une veste hop c'est pas
ça que ça se passe là il ya la brochure
qui explique exactement ce qui se passe
et qu'est-ce qu'il va y avoir dans
l'oeuf est donc la rupture elle fait
scac le fonctionnement d'une valve 15 du
hellfest cote
excusez-moi l'adhésion sur facebook il
recommandait le conecs saison numéro 4
les chapitres elle fait ce que les
events le club à la plaie la vie guidée
enfin c'est vraiment tout
qu'exceptionnelle la charte de conduite
le merchandising il ya énormément de
choses c'est vraiment un truc est super
bien packagée vraiment l'équipe du
hellfest kuyt a fait un boulot
extraordinaire ça ces sésames qui me
permettra de rentrer directement aux
elfes et scott cette magnifique soit
jean-françois je vais dormir et avec
tous les soirs le mark papa je fais ce
que tu si vous avez un gros blouson un
patch avec tous les noms de vos groupes
dessus mym
on va pouvoir compléter la collection et
puis vous verrez souvent et un packaging
qui est juste incroyable
franchement bravo à l'équipe du elphège
avait fait un boulot extraordinaire j'ai
hâte d'y être et je pense que vraiment
on va se régaler m
et
[Musique]